- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked large-brained. Lone the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here, an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Joshua] Well, thank you very much for
the introduction, Anne, and to the
organizers for inviting me to participate
in this symposium today. And also to all
of you for coming back after the break.
So, it's nice to see everyone again. So
I'm really happy to have the opportunity
to tell you about some of our recent work
on mapping archaic hominin DNA in the
genomes of modern humans. And actually my
talk, you'll see is going to be pretty
similar to our first speaker, Sriram. And
in fact when he was talking, I was
thinking to myself how nice it was,
actually, that some of the things he was
saying overlapped with what I was going to
talk about because we were working on
these projects completely independently.
We developed very different statistical
methods to answer the same questions and
yet, by and large, we came to many of the
same conclusion. So I think it engenders
confidence in the things that we're
presenting today. And my graduate student,
Benjamin Vernot and I, first became
interested in this question of archaic
admixture a few years ago. And I think
this is actually one of the most
fascinating topics in all of genetics and
genomics these days, is all of the things
that we've learned from ancient DNA
sequencing. And one of the more
contentious questions I think in human
evolution has been whether or not modern
humans mated or hybridized with archaic
humans like Neandertals and Denisovans.
And for many decades, this was just sort
of an acrimonious debate and that was
largely because the data didn't exist to
answer the question. But with technologies
developed by Svante Pääbo and some of the
other speakers we've heard from this
morning, Matias and Kay, in the not too
many years ago, we were able to get high
quality genome sequences from the
Neandertal and Denisovan genomes. And this
provided sort of unambiguous evidence that
modern humans and these archaic humans did
in fact hybridize and exchanged genes. And
as Matias talked about this morning,
though, studying ancient DNA from fossils
still remains really challenging because
you have to find an appropriate specimen,
first of all. And you have to hope that
the DNA has been preserved over hundreds
of thousands of years. So, my student and
I thought, "Well, if there was gene flow
between modern humans and archaic humans,
maybe we could excavate ancient DNA not
directly from fossils but indirectly from
the genomes of modern humans. And to give
you sort of a little bit of an intuition
of how this works, I'd like to argue that
a little bit of archaic introgression goes
a long way. And so, in this schematic, I'm
showing you a picture of 10 or so
individuals. These aren't random
individuals, these are my colleagues in
the Department of Genome Sciences, and
this is what happens when you put your
picture on the internet. So, each line
here, let's imagine, represents a stretch
of each person's genome and from previous
work, we knew that all non-Africans had
about 2% of their DNA inherited from
Neandertal ancestors. And that's what's
represented by these yellow chunks of
sequence. And so what we wanted to do was
developed a method where we could walk
along an individuals genome and pull out
the parts that were inherited from the
Neandertal ancestors. And the key here is
that the 2% of my genome that was
inherited from Neandertals might be a
little bit different than your 2%. So that
when we aggregate the data across many
individuals, we can actually recover a
substantial amount of the Neandertal
genome. And actually, what I find most
compelling about this approach is that as
opposed to sequencing ancient DNA from a
single fossil, by recovering these all
surviving archaic lineages, we're
potentially getting data that was...or
getting sequences that were inherited from
multiple archaic ancestors. So we're
getting population level data and that
will allow us to make inferences that are
difficult or impossible to do if you just
have genetic data from a single
individual. So, I'm not going to talk a
lot about the details of how we scan along
an individual's genome and look for
archaic sequence, but I did want to give
you a little bit of intuition. So what are
the characteristics of introgressed
archaic sequence that we look at? Well,
what I'm showing you here is a simple
schematic showing that Europeans diverged
from Africans about 80,000 years ago or
so. And what we want to find, or if we
look at lineages, super-imposed on this
tree, we can see that what we're actually
interested in finding are cases like this.
So sequences that are found in
non-Africans that were inherited from a
Neandertal ancestor. So what are the
features that we expect for these types of
sequences? Well, the first is that in
contrast to two modern human sequences
that have a much more recent common
ancestor, mutation will have had a long
time to act and accumulate. We want to
find these sequences. So mutation will
have had a longer time to act and
accumulate on this lineage compared to two
modern human lineages. But the other key
feature is that admixture happened
relatively recently. So in the last 60 to
80,000 years or so, and therefore the
Neandertal haplotypes will still persist
over sizable genomic regions. So, it's
this combination of highly divergent
sequences that stretch over large genomic
distances that allow us to accurately and
robustly predict what are archaic
sequences versus what are modern human
sequences. And actually the approach we're
using is a modification of a statistic
called S* that was developed by Jeff Wall.
And one of the nice things about this
approach is it doesn't explicitly use the
Neandertal or Denisovan genome when making
the initial inference. And the really
powerful thing about that is we can
potentially discover archaic lineages from
groups that we don't even know about yet,
and actually that's a major part of what
we're looking at now, but that will have
to be a story for a different day. So what
I'm going to tell you about, though, is
applying this method to 1,500
geographically diverse individuals. So
whole genome sequences from about 1,500
people all throughout the world. These are
largely sequences from the 1000 Genomes
project. So this is a publicly available
data set. But to supplement this, we also
sequenced, in collaboration with Svante
Pääbo's group, 35 individuals from
Melanesia. And the idea here was that we
knew from previous work that these
individuals should have substantial
amounts of both Neandertal and Denisovan
sequence. And if we look at the amount of
archaic ancestry that we find per
individual, that's what I'm showing on
this slide. So this shows the distribution
of the amount of archaic sequence per
individual in Melanesians, East Asians,
South Asians and Europeans. And you can
see that Melanesians have, on average,
much more archaic sequence per individual
compared to some of the other non-African
groups. And the reason is, as I just
mentioned, they have substantial amounts
of both Neandertal and Denisovan sequence.
And so each row here is an individual and
the bar plot corresponds to how much
Neandertal versus Denisovan sequence each
individual has. And if you look closely,
there's a small amount of sequence that we
label as ambiguous. This is sequence that
we are confident is archaic in origin, but
we can't distinguish, robustly at least,
whether or not it's Neandertal or
Denisovan, okay? So on average, Europeans
have about 50 to 55 megabases of archaic
sequence per individual and this is
largely Neandertal in origin. South Asians
have a little bit more, East Asians have a
little bit more. And Melanesians have
about, on average, 100 megabases of
archaic sequence per individual. So that's
100 million base pairs. So that's great,
we can identify archaic sequence. But I
think the really interesting thing is the
things that we can potentially learn from
it. So, what are the types of questions
that surviving archaic lineages allow us
to ask? So I'm going to tell you about
three things that we've been interested
in. So the first is, was hybridization
between archaic humans and modern humans
deleterious? That is, were there bad
consequences? Conversely, was
hybridization beneficial? Or, were there
some good consequences of hybridization?
And finally, what demographic model is
consistent with patterns of introgressed
archaic sequences? So let's start with the
first question. Were there deleterious
consequences to hybridization? And one of
the most striking things that we found
when first looking at patterns of
Neandertal sequence across the genome is
that it's very heterogeneously
distributed. So I'm showing you sequences
from chromosome seven, eight and nine. So
the blue ticks represent places where we
find Neandertal sequence in European
individuals. The red lines indicate places
where we find Neandertal sequence in East
Asian individuals. And the grey lines
represent parts of the genome that are too
repetitive for us to study and be
confident in the predictions from. And so,
if you squint long enough at this figure,
you can see that it doesn't appear, and
Sriram mentioned this earlier, that
patterns of surviving sequence are sort of
randomly distributed across the
chromosomes. But you find these regions
that have been called deserts or
depletions of archaic ancestry that extend
over really large genomic regions. And
this is consistent with there being
deleterious consequences to having
Neandertal sequence in these regions. And
in fact, when we do extensive simulations
and try to model this process, we see that
there is an excess in the observed data of
these depletions or archaic deserts
compared to simulated data under neutral
models of evolution. So what does that
mean? It just means basically that under
neutral evolution, so where there's no
fitness consequences to the Neandertal
sequence, we really wouldn't expect to see
deserts this large in the real data. So I
think this is pretty compelling evidence
that there was deleterious fitness
consequences to hybridization and what's
really kind of fascinating to me is that
if you also superimpose Denisovan
sequences on top of this data, you find
that there's a significant overlap between
Neandertal deserts and Denisovan deserts.
So the same places in the human genome
that are depleted of Neandertal sequences
are also depleted of Denisovan sequences.
And again, this is very consistent with
the idea that these regions maybe are
harboring genetic changes that are very
important to modern human phenotypes. So
for example, the largest region, or the
largest depletion, is on chromosome seven.
It's about a 15 megabase desert. So
there's lots of genes. One of the
challenges in interpreting these regions
is that in a 15 megabase sequence, there's
about 100 genes or so. So you don't
actually know which one is driving the
signal that you're interested in. But one
thing that caught our eye, and as Sriram
mentioned this morning, is right in the
middle of this largest desert is a gene
called FOXP2. And FOXP2 has previously
been associated with being important in
speech and language. And in fact, work
from Svante's group has shown that there's
human-specific mutations in regulatory
regions of FOXP2. So again, I want to be
careful here and we haven't proven that
FOXP2 is driving this depletion of
Neandertal sequence in this region, but
it's really interesting and I think these
deserts of archaic ancestry can help us
pinpoint places in the human genome that
might be important in modern human
evolution. So the search space is much
narrower now compared to when we first did
these studies. Another question that we
were interested in asking is, well so it
seems like there were some deleterious
consequences to hybridization, was there
also evidence that maybe some of the
sequences we picked up from Neandertals or
Denisovans, was that beneficial? And
probably the simplest way to look at this
question is to look at the frequency of
Neandertal or Denisovan sequences in
modern populations. And that's what I'm
showing you here, so each dot represents a
frequency of either a Neandertal or a
Denisovan haplotype in East Asians,
Europeans, Melanesians and South Asians.
And you can see that for the most part,
the vast majority of archaic sequence that
persists in modern human populations is
pretty rare. So usually less than 10%
frequency. But there's a number of regions
that have risen to high frequency, to 60%
in some cases, and some cases even a
little bit higher. And we've done
extensive modeling, again, to try to
determine how likely it is to see these
high frequency haplotypes in the absence
of selection. And it turns out that above
50% or so, it's actually really unusual
for a haplotype to randomly drift up to
such high frequencies. So there's about
100 or so, I think, really high confident
targets of adaptive introgression. And you
might wonder, "So what phenotypes were
influenced by adaptive introgression?" And
so, we knew previously that a version of a
gene called EPAS1 in certain Tibetan
populations was inherited from Denisovans
and it's this gene that allows them to
live at high altitude. So there was
already some pretty good a priori evidence
that admixture with archaic humans was
beneficial for some genes. And when we
look carefully at these 100 high frequency
archaic haplotypes, we see that they are
largely comprised of genes that can be
categorized into two classes. One, the
immune system. So many genes that
influence immune phenotypes. And in
particular, innate immunity. So the part
of our immune system that deals with
viruses and bacteria. So that seems to be
a very enriched target or substrate of
adaptive introgression. And I think you
could have predicted this a priori so it's
known that the immune system is often a
target of selection. But the other
category of genes that actually I would
have never predicted a priori turns out to
be a number of genes that have important
functions in skin biology. So for example,
one of these genes, as Sriram mentioned,
is BNC2. It's a gene called Basonuclin2
that has recently been shown to influence
skin pigmentation levels in Europeans. So
it's a very high frequency. Each row here
again is an individual and columns are
variant sites. And these individuals carry
the Neandertal haplotype. And you can see
that it's a very high frequency haplotype
in Europeans not found in East Asians. And
finally and real quickly, I'm just going
to give you a brief synopsis on the things
we can learn about demographic models. And
whenever I think of demographic models,
this image from National Geographic comes
to mind. I think it's sort of a
fascinating picture actually. My kids
really like this, too, because they say I
look like him, but that's a different
story. And so, what are the things that we
can try to learn? Well, we want to know
things like when did hybridization happen?
How many times did it happen? Did
different populations have the same or
different admixture histories? Now I have
a post-doc, Joshua Schreiber, who
developed a really clever method of trying
to infer whether two populations had the
same admixture history or different
admixture histories. And so, when we apply
this method to pairs of populations that
we analyzed, the details here aren't
important, but we can infer sort of this
general picture of... So this is
Europeans, East Asians, Melanesians,
Africans, Neandertals and Denisovans. And
the main point I want to impress upon you
is that maybe even compared to as recently
as a few years ago, it seems like the
admixture history between modern and
archaic humans is much more complex. And
in fact, the data is consistent with
multiple pulses of admixture between
Neandertals and modern humans. And at
least one pulse of admixture with
Denisovans. So in conclusion, I've shown
you that substantial amounts of the
Neandertal and Denisovan genome remain
scattered in the DNA of modern humans,
that there were fitness consequences to
hybridization, both good and bad, and that
the history of contact was much more
complex than previously thought. And I
would like to thank people in my lab. So
this guy right here in the middle is
Benjamin Vernot. He was a graduate student
who is now a post-doc with Svante Pääbo,
but he by and large did most of the work
that I talked about today. So with that, I
will thank you and I guess answer
questions after everyone's done.
♪ [music] ♪